we left for college in the fall of 77
the school was you know well known for
the business education that it had at
that time and it was really emerging as
a leader in thought process about kind
of an independence liberal arts
experience that I had was very important
to beginning to discover both the world
around you and yourself a little bit so
I think for me it was a real
appreciation for areas that I don't know
that I would have taken myself too had I
not had opportunity to go to Hillsdale I
met my wife there we were engaged my
senior year Mary and I both have just
great memories of our time together at
Hillsdale it's the people that you
always remember the your professors that
had an impact on you your friends it was
just to me a magical experience I was
engaged when I came out of college got
married right away started in the
banking business it was 1981 the economy
was a wreck been basically with three
companies during that time period I had
an opportunity to work for people that I
had respect for people that gave me
opportunities for the last decade or so
I've been either a president or a CEO in
the banking business the company with
today's headquartered in Detroit
having merged Chemical Bank and TCF the
last merger was my 26th merger or
acquisition the industry has just been
changing at the light of speed it's
going to continue so while I spend a
tremendous amount of time in the banking
business say spent significant a lot of
time in organizational development
incredibly honored to be receiving the
Distinguished Alumni Award
they had a great a career there I've got
lifelong friends from there I went to
school with people that I have so much
respect for that I've done things that I
think completely eclipsed what I've done
during my career but I'm truly proud of
my association with Hillsdale honored to
receive this award and will cherish it
[Music]